the idea of ​​this talk of saying in 20 in
20 be the same is because it doesn't happen to them that
now everything has to be a measure
any business problem be it
free market be it awards
I don't know if you know the company but it is the
platform that connects  freelancers
with clients have these objects
spotify we also saw yesterday they have these
objects in their world clients songs
works products that when
doing machine learning they first started
with the most typical myths more let's put together
a little board let's get features
manually let's put them in oslo assisted
come back sbm and  let's try to do something
with that and that's it they were
doing for the last 34 years and now they
want to go to the next step of putting
these beautiful neural networks that work great in
the academy but that
in the industry it's not so easy to
apply them
put this for  generate new
representations that have
much more complex semantics and what is
the problem the problem is that we are
usually representing
human phenomena and we humans are both
computers so our
behavior is very erratic and very
difficult to predict so many
times we don't even
agree on what
defines a phenomenon I in particular
was working with
educational data let's say when you  they are
taking a course either because it is based on
an intelligent tutor that they can give
a little boy or the module they are carrying out
actions they are leaving traces of what they
were doing in those data they are
raised and can be used to predict
different things one of  those things is
dropout whether or not they are going to drop out of the course by
reading the literature on what licensed
educational psychologists
of all kinds say about why they
drop out, students have not the slightest
idea, that is, there are a lot of theories but they
don't get there  a consensus and the same is going to
happen with any other
business problem that you have because a
client  leave a contract average we
don't know it's the first thing we have to
explore
then not only is it difficult to
understand but teaching it to a
machine is even worse whatever we do
so that the machine grasps and models
this real world problem
then why is this important
we are learning representations
learning them instead because machine learning
is trying to grab a
phenomenon that we don't know about which
can also be language that is
determined by a lot of
latent causes and they were at the
pl n guys talk yesterday which was great
and we saw the framework models with
hidden states well we do
n't know those latent states so
we have to grab our
data and somehow convert it into
a representation that is as
close as possible to these latent causes
I already see if you know it I speak  of what
it is to intertwine say tango the
latent causes that dominate in a phenomenon
So if our representation is
well attached to the latent causes, a
logistic regression is going to be able to
classify your problem without now, the
further that
representation is from the latent causes,
the classifier is going to have to do a
lot of work
to be able to untangle them.  same and
try to find out why the
student leaves because the
work stays half the contract is not finished
then this leads us to three
needs the first one everyone knows
because computers do not understand
anything other than making us zeros and ones  yes
then yes or yes we have to pass all
the entities of our
business problem to a quoted vector of
dense numbers if it's dense it's better then there are
a couple of mathematical properties of
why that happens but basically it has
to be a set of numbers
convenience  is this that we are
talking about that the closer
we have our representation to the
data, the easier and  s to learn it and
finally the formalization and this is
something that cost me a lot to understand because
I started as a lot of data before saying
let's do in the tensor flow from tutorial
amount in surf you washed efe and we started
to make a neural network and you give your
data and get  I want it like this
and what did you think before necklace
not many times that is the problem of the
massive nature of
artificial intelligence tutorials that we do not
stop to think about what we are doing
so if we think about the
formalization in the data we begin to
understand much better  what is our
problem, for example, in the case of
educational data mining,
a psychologist was scandalized because she says
how the students are representing
based only on what they do in the course,
a person is much more complex than
that without being completely right  world
that but they are the only data
I have so when formalizing it I
determined well how  They are the causes that
I am going to be able to model and which ones I will not if the
boy gave me a fever he broke is the
good one the dog is not I will never know
my data and that type of phenomena
will give us an upper limit
so that on  all daybreak no do
n't come and ask us I want 99% of the
cure 99 percent of the crisis it's not
possible gentlemen in many cases then it
is very good to think in advance how
we are going to represent our data and what
information is
well inside this  In this case, we are going to talk
particularly about
student modeling and the content in
these online courses. Think that a
student is interacting, he is opening
the lesson, one is watching video 34, he is
taking some test and this video lesson
etc. with which he goes  interacting are
called the contents then both
concepts have to be modeled and
we are going to try to model them
in a way that follows the
intuitions we have about the process of
e  Let's say
then there is something that we never do either,
which is to go back to how things are modeled,
many of you have not
had models and simulations,
models and something that has to do with
statistics, I did not understand you, I
did not know what not to model  Until about the
third year of my doctorate because I couldn't
communicate how to unite those two
abstract concepts with the PRI concept, that is,
the concept that I wanted to
study, which was the students,
until I began to read papers with a little more
attention then  a very
successful way in fact that I had to model
students is to say well my student
is a real number and my action is a
real number
and they model how these
two entities interact and model with those formulas
which is horrible
but well there is the  statistical part
it doesn't matter what that formula is doing
but the truth is that to the
computer we are saying the world is
like that things are re  they relate like this
and things can be rescued from here for
example although in the two arrows it is
somehow taking the difference in
the distance between the student and the
content now
intuitively that is very valuable if my
student knows that my lesson is very far away my
lesson means  that it can know very
little in which case it will not learn anything
or too much in which case it will not learn
anything either because it will not have anything new to
learn and if it is very close we can
maximize learning then how
far to be and how far away our little
dots are  in this space it is important
for this problem I don't know how, for
example, to model vladan in spotify it must
surely have other relationships between
the entities of this space
well then we have another example
that is where we rely heavily
on the network and perhaps the students  it
begins to model them as vectors as it is
more like a sequence of vectors that
as it takes different
interactions it changes  changing its status,
which is understandable, not every time you
watch a video you learn or at least the
sports part is capable, it is not positive
and the contents
well formalize this concept that a
lesson can actually be represented
as the vector of things that made you
we still need to know about prerequisites
and again we have a
very very fixed formula how these
two things are related and why in that delta function
it is also encoding the distance
between these two vectors in particular
I think it was using the dot product
many times  sometimes heard from a distance and
excuse me mathematicians I am not
talking about a distance in the
formal sense but a distance as
the rest of us mortals understand it
so here we enter into a problem
what is the eyebrow that you give to your
classifier versus the variance that you go
waiting for that they classified this what
does it mean you have domain information
that you know is useful to
solve your problem
vers  you don't want to tell the
classifier
this is the little formula for how the world
works but you know you have
highly heterogeneous data because we're
modeling users from all over the world and
how do you keep those two in
balance without spending too much money
mainly because one of the  things that
can be done is to start recording data
if in this case you place
the domain information in the data for
example if in the case of spotify they said
this song is good and this song
is bad because some song expert
decided it on  In this case, that is to
say, we are going to model this exercise
as if it teaches linear algebra and
teaches first degree equations,
so something is printing the bias
of what you know is important
to solve your problem of whether the
student is going to drop out or not.  the
student or not directly learn
the data if you have 3 million data you
need 3 million annotations and
that is not good  So there is another
way to combine this, which is to inject
domain knowledge into a
model that is not a formula
but a neural network, and thus you avoid or
help the classifier to predict with
more information without having to get
into the data
itself.  you are starting to understand
that it is a network you don't see the select
behind but well you know I am going to assume
that you know what a neural network is and
why it is good for this problem
well for this because they are flexible they are
capable of learning any function
that you want  which does not mean
that they are going to learn it that they are capable of
learning it they are powerful enough
then to model this
human phenomenon that is so complex and
finally because they are totally
malleable then we can start to
get hands on and be creative with the
architecture that we are going to  use from behind
then the next question
is how are we going to model these in beige
time how are we going to implement it are we going
to  make the code excuse me I did not bring
any film not with code but it is
entered so in this case we have
sequential data whether the student is
performing different interactions
then we are going to use a recurrent neural network
because it has this ability
to remember to give it in an
introductory way because  The recurring ones
have the ability to remember because they
maintain a hidden state that is
updated after each new
entry, that is, every time we see a
new exercise, this state is updated
back
and this cult state is updated with two
entries, what was there before
hidden state and the action or entity that
we just saw
then what it says I think it's a
stanford student what a good idea
this method in 2015 well until we
have a quoted vector of things that
is updated over time and
that this vector saved the information
seen up to that moment because we did not use
this vector as the e-mail of the student  student
if then in that way we can
understand a piece of the neural network
as the representation as the mbe ding
of some of my characteristics
and until that moment we had not said
anything about the environments the contents
how we do to generate content in media
is very easy  you put a layer of measurement
on those and it is good to understand what you are not
doing but when you go to the
steaks where everything is programmed
I have four lines if you put a layer
of medellín with that you
are simply projecting this information of
the reactions  to a dense vector of low
dimensionality 200 300 and the network by
itself will take care of learning which
were the
most relevant causes for the task that you
wanted to optimize and then we
take advantage of the use
of networks so as not to have to do  a
horrible way like what we saw before
and how we inject now this
concept that the distance between the student
and the content of the course  or it is relevant
well
we take the distance and that's it
we grab the 2m dix they have to be the
same size like this like that and we take some
intuition of distance between the two
then now the new state of the
student is going to be calculated based on
two things the state of the  student that I
had before and not the mbe link of my new
interaction but how far that
student was from that action that we get
with that if the student was
too far away well in this case the
distance is going to be too
small others too big but we are
going to  pass a function so that this
doesn't happen fluidity the further away
we are we are going to turn off the signal of the
neural network because this lesson is
not going to be contributing anything to the
change of the student but it is going to be
the normal change from one interaction to
another yes  we are very close we maximize the
signal that comes from the representation of
the lesson so the student
learned a lot and his state changed a lot
and that  we achieved good there as you can see
in the figure by changing the input of the
recurring layer which was approximately 15
lines of code
and another thing that we experienced that
we think is good but that I can also
learn more about the
lessons for that though  I have few
annotated data that tell me this
student I leave this student I don't leave
if I have a lot of traces
probably that are not annotated
of which I can't as if it were
natural language begin to see how
the reactions are related and if the
lesson if well  in election 1 2 and 3 and
xosé that 1 and 3 are from unit 1 it
is very likely that lesson 2 will also
be from unit well if then we are going
to do exactly the same thing that we
talked about doing with spotify let's go  to
pass a beck orchard and that is going to give us
an initial representation that is
understood somewhat from the initial lessons we
create the mbe dix layer with that
representation and then we also have
the option  ion of find tune it together with the
rest of the network or leave it there as fixed
this is going to be the representation of the
lessons and points
so now how do we optimize this if
we are just saying that we
do not have as much data annotated
and what you can let go is that  you
have some data written down but not
exactly what you wanted if you
have to predict the
weight and height of your products in mercadolibre
you may have some
past information but you also have
how much they charged you for
sending that product, for example
you can try to optimize a model
so that it predicts how much you charged
instead of taking it out and putting it in
a task where you're going to have much less
data written down that it's going to try to
predict the and the width and the height of the
product if they are tasks that are  more or
less related because if it was very
big guys they don't charge much to wear it
but they are not exactly the same and that's
where we get into what the task is  as a
pretext that serves you to obtain
your representation versus the task that
you really want to do then when
one does not have many resources in the case
of mercadolibre but for the rest of the
people
out there rethink and see what are
the things that you can learn from the
data is quite useful and you can extract
things that are really valuable
so good for what he just
said first we train with a
pretext task we extract that in beijing which
was what we were interested in and
then we can evaluate then apply it
to any other  task that we want that
in general is called
application task as doctors are not
those people who do not have resources I did not
have access to any other to do those
except the one with which they enter is then
in my case the pretext task and the
application task are the same because
well I didn't get more data but if I
had had access to a live course
and could have done avoid sting or  something
like this could have been tried with some other
task
and well here he mentioned the two tasks
that I use so that it is
known that this works for many
things and what are the points where
you have to stop and think about what you
are doing  In the first one, it is not
racing, which is knowledge tracing,
which is about predicting after
having seen what the
student who knows and does not know does. The
problem is what are the concepts that
you can get to know or not know,
then  it is something that has to be defined and
the advantage of neural methods is
that you are going to say again you have to know or you
may or may not know two hundred things which is
the size of your representation you have
200 dimensions in which your data
can have more or less  values ​​and
that represents the knowledge of the
student if the neural network is going to
be in charge of deciding what those
skills are and this is very important
we will never know which one it said let's
see  which are 200 we can
find some correlation between one
of the neurons
its performance in things with linear algebra
but we will never be able to
directly interpret what the contrast of that is, we
return to the methods that had the
little formula and where you said the
dimension  one is linear algebra
dimension two is equations of dimension
three is I don't know
geometry etcetera is flexibility but
on the other hand walls interprets
ability and in many in many businesses it is
interpreted by ability the esplana
ability is crucial to be able to
explain what the network is doing  and he does
n't freising them it's true the
prediction group is to predict if the student is
going to drop out or not and here the questions are
what it means to drop out it means that he didn't
give up at the end that he didn't come back or that I
didn't pay you for the certificate because the
three  are very valid but the definition
of drop out is there fuzzy media
this method or the neural network and final
can be applied to any  Out of
all these scenarios
and also the great question of the century is
when can we know with certainty about
a future event if, after
how many weeks or how many days after
it returned to us, can we say that it is not going to
return and send him an email and  With that, I
am going to leave the question for you to
explain to Anna,
but report learning, which is a
good way to do it,
and we are going to see how, even when you
try to solve it only with
neural networks,
the difference when we go to the
implementation of these two tasks.  it is
that you are not interested in what
they are labeled from sequences
what is on the left side
of the screen for each input you get
an output be you read this the
student's interaction and update
the status of how much he knew or how much  I
didn't know while it entered drop out
prediction you read the whole sequence and
at the end you say if it's going to leave or not or if
here you have a single error signal to
optimize a s  sequence of more than thousands
of interactions and that is a
headache because the lcm in theory works
if it does not have several ingredients when
you go to practice all that is a lie
well we have a fairly basic idea
of ​​how we are going to program this and the issue
is  How are we going to evaluate it many times,
especially when we are doing
tutorials and we don't download it to the
industry, we absolutely forget
what the evaluation was, we grab and
say this to an f1 of 079 and what
do we do with it
before we get to evaluate that  I forgot
I have to enter a meeting no I
am not going to go into detail about the
nightmare that is that in this
particular case that for prediction clothing I
had 38 different courses so I had
to train and evaluate the optimal model
for 38 courses that I did not  they could have
nothing to do with each other so
this part we are going to pretend that
there is no magic and someone trained us on the
network we are going to move on to how we evaluate
first  define what are the things that
I am going to compare let's say the ones you want to
know work or not work then
you have to compare something that worked
without your model versus it works with your
model and in this case we have three
options the l 7 mp the the stm with the
content shipments, that is, we are
modeling content and students and
finally where we model them
together, that is why we call it as
in beijing when what we model is the
distance between the student and the
lesson
and we also have this other
dimension in which we can evaluate that
if  we use in random trained billings
initialized randomly
or if we use in berlin
with a pre trained with the uex guard
then for the first task what we
got is that beautiful little board that if you
read papers you will see it is
everywhere right now and do in our little number
that it was better than the others so
we were very happy with that but
what does it matter if you have one
more number  great if you have to go to a
course designer and you tell him my
model has 175 there is no learning from
that you cannot make
business decisions from that then it is a
big problem that we see in how we are
comparing and evaluating in the networks
Neuronals in academia Probably
people from industries know all this,
which is to stay with the highest result, it
is more to know if our model
is better or not, it is not even enough for us
with that little number, why, because
going back to the training part, well,
I have to try many
combinations of neural networks thousands
of combinations of neural networks of
and prepare meters to get a
neural network now layers of chance gave
one that minimized the problem found a
minimum that was great because it
started on the side of that minimum
randomly yes
and if you listed these reports
hiding everything that cost you and
what is the real probability that you
have of finding that performance
in  So one more step that can be taken is to
try to graph the distribution of
the results that you get in this
case the area under the curve is a
binary prediction performance metric and basically the
higher the better if then in this case
we see what remains  a little lighter than
green the stm is more convenient
than red yes because not only does it have a
maximum value but you have a very low
probability of basically finding the
most likely value which is the median of
red which is marked with a line
and  Well, what you see there are different
intuitions of what distance meant,
different functions such as the
pass, which I am not going to go into detail about,
but the best models it made. I look at this
graph. I tell you for sure that the
best model is tan h, despite the fact that
its maximum value is not so different from that of
the lcm because because the one of the tan h
obtained a much smaller distribution of results,
then there is a greater
probability of hitting  a good model
with the medium I just wanted to show
that for some cases between training
your in billings post that
really gives you better results it leaves us a
lot of time so it is something to
really investigate and try
so until now we have been doing very well
in the doctorate  about
half with results that looked like they
were good
and we started with the second task to
evaluate this method a little bit more
strongly which was the prediction of
quits and we got this little table that
well it wasn't that good but at least it
didn't get worse with what  which when one is
doing a doctorate may
never work yes then these at
least worked it was a very good sign
until he returned to study a subject and
if a final project and I took these data
and analyzed them better I analyzed them from a
point of view  more great fisher castet
but so many neural networks I ended up
testing a logistic relationship that
gave me better than the one of the stma
that is
That's why he had to put up with me for those
weeks, so after coming back it's
good when he spends a moment of pressure
investigating more data, it happens in a
decision tree and you get angry at
the most important files and surprise
the most important files were the
number of interactions that
the student had done, that is, if you are
reaching the end of the course, it is more
likely that you will not leave the number of
sessions, which is how many times you
sat in front of the computer and
worked with this and the number of
videos and exercises that
you were effectively accessing  in proportion to the
other contents, the people who accessed
lessons and did not access exercises sold
more than quit and here we return to what we
said at the beginning this representation
is super attached to the causes that I
understand will determine if someone
quits or does not quit then  or the staff or
if this regression or a decision tree
and it works then the neural network is not
the answer to  all neural networks
are the answers when you
don't have the time or resources to make
a worthwhile representation
when you've already done it you want to try something
new which I suppose is the case for
many companies
or when you have no idea of ​​the problem
you don't know what  it is what is happening
in this data space
finally to talk with a
positive result we started to investigate a
little more what these results were
because we saw the 38 courses and not in
all the courses it was so bad
then we saw that for the smaller courses
this representation where
we were actively modeling
the distance between the student and the
content worked much better because
because we had less data and to
train a network you need a lot of data
so with injecting it and domain or
domain information you were
compensating a bit for your lack of data and
the  network ended up learning better than
if you don't put that then in trouble
where you have  little data is a good
option to try crazy things
finally I do this super fast
but it's because visualization is
in my soul and I have to say something
about it well we as you know
neural e-mails are criticized because
you can't understand them so we
We said let's see if we can
understand them and we started to have graphs
like that. In fact, there is a paper that
analyzes this type of graphs and tells you
things like the little worms that are
forming, well, those little worms come from the fact
that the student's state is
changing.  Little by little, then,
a little path is formed, lie graphs,
text, and it is exactly the same as this
is a property that comes from the
algorithm that you use to graph and not
so much from the data, so when
trying to analyze these highly
dimensional things that  represent
complex phenomena be careful because when they
want to find patterns they will find
patterns if then in the end what n  What
remained for you is that you could not always
find it or if you could interpret this in
measure but some things
yes again this piece of information we had
but it was good to see it reflected in the
representation here we are seeing a
graph
that is projecting the place where it
was with all the students
while they were doing the course and the
color that represents the time then
all the students start in the
area that is lighter and they
moved together towards the area that is
darker yes then that means that
this representation that is projected
using psa or  be main component
analysis is getting me the directions
of greatest variation is capturing this
notion that one of the most
important filters was how many lessons you had
done in the course and some things can
be learned by looking at them with great
care and if we have it only the
last point where did they stay I think
the color is not very good but more or
less it separated you q  that the students
who did not drop out were on one
side and the students who did drop out
were on the other,
so to close what we learned,
that is, you
first learned that by working a little more
on your representation you can
help improve your performance  that the
domain injection is something ugly when
you do it in the data but it is not so ugly
when you do it in the model if it can
help you have to be creative the redesign
of the task like this that we did to
predict to look at the smallest courses
or we even did others where we
predicted only with a piece of the
course and we tried to see how much
information we needed to be able to
predict well it is a very good way to
evaluate your performance and that finally they do
not keep the maximum f1
look at the distribution look at other things compare  different
metrics because the evaluation is one
more part of the training process
that we often leave aside and
fine  Please think before you take and use
the information first to inform
the various rights thank you very much
[Applause]
and